es gibt schon seit langem Zeiten Armut
Armut in einem der reichsten Länder und
der der Pandemie hat die Armut
zugenommen wir liegen jetzt bei einer
Quote von 16,6 Prozent hat der
Paritätische Wohlfahrtsverband erhoben
in diesem Jahr das sind fast 14
Millionen Menschen die von
Einkommensarmut betroffen sind
in so einem reichen Land ist das nicht
zu akzeptieren arm zu sein hier bedeutet
früher sterben zu müssen weil man das
reiste mit dem ärmsten Viertel der
Bevölkerung vergleicht sterben Frauen
viereinhalb Jahre früher
Männer achteinhalb Jahre früher also arm
zu sein bedeutet eben nicht auf
irgendwelche Konsumgüter verzichten zu
müssen sondern arm zu sein bedeutet
kränker zu sein eine höhere
depressionsrate zu haben auch eine
höhere Suizidrate mehr Herzinfarkte bis
hin zu einer geringeren Lebenserwartung
arm zu sein bedeutet dass 43 Prozent
aller alleinstehenden in 88 Prozent sind
das Mütter von Armut betroffen sind wie
kann es sein dass der Familienstatus so
sehr mit Armut verbunden ist jeder
dritte dritte paarhaushalt mit drei und
mehr Kindern ist von Einkommensarmut
betroffen das kann doch nicht sein alle
Politiker sagen immer Sie machen was
gegen Kinderarmut die Kinderarmut nimmt
zu jedes fünfte Kind ist von Armut
betroffen und das in einem reichen Land
Reichtum nimmt zu Armut nimmt zu und in
dem Zusammenhang ist es mir wichtig wir
dürfen nicht Armut gegen Armut
ausspielen Lösungsvorschlag Armut finden
wir alles schlimm das ist ja normal ich
weiß nicht ich glaube manchmal ist Armut
auch ein ja so wie es bei uns
praktiziert wird wie man in die Armut
Gerät dass das so ein abschreckungs
vielleicht Szenario auch ist wenn du
nicht funktionierst in dieser
Leistungsgesellschaft dann wirst du
bestraft was ist die Lösung die Lösung
ist zum Beispiel der Steuersatz das
Bürgergeld muss mindestens um 200 Euro
erhöht werden das fordern alle Kirchen
alle wohlwartsverbände die nationale
Armutskonferenz ein mietpreisdeckel muss
es geben im Gesundheitssektor darf es
keine weitere Privatisierung
durch eine Umverteilung es muss eine
Vermögenssteuer geben in Deutschland die
bertsmannstiftung hat eine Untersuchung
eine repräsentative Befragung
durchgeführt 76 Prozent der Deutschen
sind für eine Vermögenssteuer 75% sind
dafür dass der Staat mehr gegen Armut
tut ja also diese Umverteilung es muss
auch eine modifizierte Erbschaftssteuer
geben und es muss eine höhere Einkommen
also höhere Erbschaftssteuer ja das muss
modifiziert sein ja es wird ja immer so
suggeriert dann wird man die dass das
Einfamilienhaus das noch von der Oma
geerbt hat verlieren so sehen die
modernen Einfamilienhaus
einer Doppelhaushälfte finden Sie dass
die Steuern in Deutschland zu niedrig
sind und höhere erbschafts- und
Vermögenssteuer haben muss also ich
glaube dass wir noch sehr viel mehr
Armut sehen werden dass das Deutschland
nicht so reich ist wie er sich das
vorstellt ich sehe das bei uns wir haben
jetzt jahrelang nullzinsen gehabt man
konnte nicht sparen weil der Staat hat
Geld ausgegeben wie ein Weltmeister weil
er ja am Geld ausgeben verdient hat denn
bei nullzinsen leihen wir dem Staat das
Geld für minuszinsen wir dürfen
praktisch wir zahlen den Start dafür
dass er unser Geld aufbewahrt das hat
dazu geführt dass die gesamte
Bevölkerung sich nichts mehr zurückert
legen können das heißt was früher für
uns in unserer Generation noch
selbstverständlich war dass man nach dem
Arbeitsamt Leben sich ein Häuschen
gebaut hat ist völlig ausgeschlossen
kein Mensch kann sich heute ein Haus
leisten wir sind in ganz Europa die
letzten wir haben am wenigsten
Immobilienbesitz wie alle anderen
Europäer also das reiche Deutschland ist
gerade dabei zusammenzubrechen aber
Steuern betrifft aber bei Steuern
betrifft sind wir ja schon auf Platz
zwei vor uns ist noch Belgien aber
ansonsten zahlen wir Deutschen ja schon
die meisten Steuern ich will damit sagen
ich gebe ihnen wir starten die
eigentlich genug ein in der Stadt nimmt
genug haben aber der Staat wird weniger
einnehmen weil ihr auch die Einkommen
sinken werden wenn es keine
Autoindustrie mehr gibt wenn es keine
Bankenindustrie mehr gibt wenn es keine
Chemie Abwanderung auch von
Industriezweigen weil ja vor allen
Dingen das Schließen dann was er mit dem
Know-how passiert möchte ich gar nicht
erst wissen aber ich sage nur wenn er
jetzt schon von Armut Schmäh es wird
noch viel schlimmer werden wenn sie sagt
wir holen einmal die andere rein wir
wollen alle ihre Argumente heute Abend
noch hören nein nein nein wir holen
einmal die anderen bleiben verfügt über
50% Vermögen aber das mit meine Zeit zum
Beispiel sind schon die Vize Steuer
Weltmeister sind ist wahr das heißt der
Start im eigenen Vermögenssteuer
Deutschland hat keine Vermögenssteuer
ich würde gerne einmal Herrn Knabe
fragen weil ich habe gerade ich habe
gerade aufgehorcht als die Fürsten von
von den Sachen gesprochen hat die uns
bevorstehen das befürchte ich auch noch
mehr Armut gibt es Parallelen zu den
20er Jahren die Frage stelle ich mir
ganz oft
ja das wären keine schönen Aussichten
wie wir alle wissen wo die Arbeitslosen
dann in die extremen Parteien
abgewandert sind kwd und NSDAP und dann
die Straßenschlachten in Berlin
stattfanden
ich kann nur hoffen dass es nicht dazu
kommt und sie im Moment auch nicht
wirklich eine solche Eskalation weil ich
den Eindruck habe dass vieles was ja
auch hier jetzt diskutiert worden ist
ein bisschen
wie soll ich sagen Panik mache ist wir
sind ein sehr reiches Land vielleicht
das reichste Land Europas nein und
jedenfalls kein Land was unterarmut
sichtbar leidet in dem Sinne wie man das
in anderen Ländern Europas beobachten
ja wenn sie durch die Großstädte laufen
nicht unbedingt daran das muss man eben
dann sich im Detail angucken wenn
Friedrichshain da Leute am Straßenrand
liegen die dort früher nicht lagen da
muss man sich fragen woher kommen die
aus Rumänien kommen nicht an die
Obdachlosen oder wie sie beschreiben
soll ich denke vor allem wo mir auch
jedes Mal wirklich schlecht wird das
sind die pfandflaschensammler und das
sind Rentner die Rente auf besser müssen
zum Beispiel wirklich das wurde dafür
eingeführt ich sammle auch manchmal
Pfandflaschen wenn ich die stehen sehe
damit sie eben von der Straße
verschwinden das war der Sinn der Sache
das finde ich hier gut das ist ein
schlechtes Beispiel finde ich
aber was die fürstins sagte diese große
Enteignung die eigentlich stattfindet
die finde ich wirklich skandalös ne dass
man eben
hier durch diese acht Prozent Inflation
jedes Jahr 8 Prozent dessen was man sich
vielleicht mühsam hat ansparen können
verliert 10% zu dass man leider sagen
und das ist eben Inflation ist immer
staatlich induziert also ausgelöst nicht
weil die eben über ihre Verhältnisse
gelebt haben und gerade mit
Sozialprogrammen eben viel Geld aus dem
Fenster geworfen haben ohne wirklich
zielgenau zu arbeiten deswegen finde ich
das auch mit dem Hartz IV nicht
überzeugend wenn ich das um 200 Euro
anhebe dann gibt es doch für einen
Geringverdiener überhaupt kein Anlass
mehr zur Arbeit zu nehmen
dass die Verdienste so gering noch aus
der Geschichte
noch noch ein Punkt anführen die
wirklich wie soll ich sagen
dynamischsten Gesellschaften
sind die mit großen sozialen
Unterschieden dort gibt es einen starken
Aufstiegswillen warum sind die Inder so
aufstiegsorientiert und sind jetzt in
Berlin hier überall zu sehen das hängt
mit diesem sozialgefälle zusammen und
deswegen eine Gesellschaft wo alle
gleich reich sind ist keine gute
Gesellschaft
in der alle gleich sind das wäre
sicherlich das schrecklichste weil sie
dann endgültig keinerlei Innovation mehr
haben was wir zunächst aber mal in
dieser Debatte vielleicht auch besser am
Anfang hätten klären sollen ist was denn
eigentlich Armut ist Armut ist definiert
als ein je nachdem nach
unterschiedlichen Modellen bestimmter
Anteil also Prozentanteil des
Durchschnittseinkommens 60 Prozent das
heißt wenn Sie eine Gesellschaft haben
die sagen wir mal und eine Million Euro
im Durchschnitt verdient dann ist der
der 600.000 Euro im Jahr verdient Arm
würde man jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen es
ist also insofern natürlich schon mal
vollständige Augenwischerei von der
Reduzierung Entfernung Minderung oder
auch im übrigen auch Steigerung der
Armut zu reden denn die werden sie quasi
Definition weil es reine mathematisch
Definition ist immer gleichermaßen
vorfinden es ist letztlich für mich
nichts anderes als eine weitere Ausrede
um das Rad der sozialistisch
planwirtschaftlichen Eigenschaften noch
ein Stückchen
vielleicht lernen Sie mal was der
Unterschied ist zwischen einer
Korrelation und einer Kausalität das
weiß ich sehr einfach nicht wissen sie
es nicht wenn Sie eine Kausalität
behaupten ohne sie zu belegen ist
natürlich kein krank legen Arm oder ist
der arme krank wie rum ist es richtig es
gibt den selektionseffekt der nachweist
dass chronische Krankheit zunehmend zu
einer Verarmung führen bei Erwachsenen
Armut aufwachsen getränker sind also
belehrend
bitte Sie es geht genau darum dass das
Geld dass sie umverteilen wollen erstmal
erwirtschaftet werden muss wir haben
noch einen Anteil von 14% der Menschen
die Nettozahler sind in diesem Land die
das Erwirtschaften was sie umverteilen
wollen und sie und mit ihrer
Umverteilungspolitik wollen diese Leute
auch noch als Leistungsträger
ausschließen und dafür sorgen dass die
nicht mehr arbeiten nur nehmen sie denn
das Geld hier wenn Sie die Vermögen fast
nicht behalten wovon bezahlen Sie im
nächsten Jahr das Geld aber Antworten
einmal Antworten nach dem feuerbeschuss
auf die ja genau dieses
diskriminierende und stigmatisierende
den Menschen gegenüber immer wieder wird
behauptet ob das Söder ist ob das sie
sind dass kein keine Motivation für
Arbeit mehr vorhanden wäre wenn ich
jetzt mehr Hartz IV bekomme einmal zeigt
das ganz klar dass die Löhne viel zu
niedrig sind die müssten höher sein denn
es ist nach dem Essen es ist
nachgewiesen um hier an der Gesellschaft
partizipieren zu können nachgewiesen um
ja das ist nach ist noch komischer sagen
er hat dann gucken Sie doch mal den
Armutsbericht des Papierchen Wohlfahrt
genau wir sind überhaupt nicht
informiert wir machen eine Pause hier
zwischen ihnen beiden sie bekommen jetzt
ihre These Herr lute das ist nämlich
nicht das will nach acht Niveau wir sind
hier immer respektvoll zueinander
deswegen kombinieren
die Menschen das macht sie depressiv
wenn so über sie gesprochen wenn jemand
sagt du musst das Arbeiten das wird mich
auch unfassbar depressiv machen